It's time to play Super Zeroes,
Super Zeroes.
(cheering)
I know you've never heard
of this game,
-so I appreciate your support.
-(laughter)
Superheroes are known
for having kickass backstories,
like being bit
by a radioactive spider
and gaining cool superpowers...
instead of coughing up blood
and losing all their hair.
But... not all heroes
are that lucky.
Some superheroes end up looking
like total butter crystal ball.
Uh, like this...
(laughter)
...very sexy light bulb.
-(laughter)
-Uh... but there are tons
of horrible heroes and villains
to goof on,
so let's take a look at some,
and then we'll goof.
Comedians, I'm gonna show you
some obscure comic book
characters, and for 250 points,
you answer questions about them.
First up, we have...
Matter-Eater Lad.
-(laughter) -Matter-Eater Lad.
He seems to be able to eat
any and all matter.
What is his catchphrase?
Josh.
Don't judge me,
I'm going through a breakup.
Points.
Wait a minute...
Are you sure? I think
he's on the fence about it.
Aw... Hey.
-There you go.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, come on, kids, your ol' dad
knows how to mix it up
with comedy.
Next up, how about NFL Superpro?
How about NFL Superpro?
Uh, what is his weakness?
Nick.
Uh, turning 30.
Points. Yup.
CUMMINGS:
Oh, funny.
Whitney Cummings.
Uh, his weakness
is spelling and pussy.
Points.
Josh.
His weakness is the state
of Florida's child custody laws.
Points. Yeah.
Next up, this viral sensation:
Infectious Lass.
What's the name
of her super team? Josh.
The Hepatitis Four.
Points.
Whitney.
Uh, HPV for Vendetta.
Points.
Next up, we have
Arm Fall Off Boy.
Wh...
Can we... can I...
can we just point out the sound
of your arm ripping off is...
-Yeah, yeah, it's-it's "plorp".
-Obviously plorp. -Plorp.
It's plorp. I mean, you know,
you work on Walking Dead,
a lot of people
get their limbs ripped off.
You-you probably hear
plorps all the time.
Uh, who is his sidekick?
Who is his sidekick? Josh.
The drummer from Def Leppard.
Oh, no.
No.
Togeth...
Together they can
both lift a box.
That's...
Nick.
It only makes sense
that his sidekick
-is Arm Put Back On Boy.
-Yeah, points.
That would only make sense.
Next up, beware The Fiddler!
Oh, oh.
Green is an evil color.
What is used
to defeat this villain? Nick.
A, uh, younger,
more talented Asian fiddler.
Points.
Next up, duck,
it's Codpiece!
-Here comes Codpiece.
-McDERMITT: Oh...
Uh, where did he
get his super power?
Where did he get
his super power? Josh.
Let me ask you this, Chris--
have you ever tried
(bleep) a microwave?
Mm...
I mean, like, you know,
I've 69'd one,
but I haven't, like...
We all have.
I set it to 69 and then
I hit start and then...